>>Craig: James is ready
to take his project
out to Mrs. Wright's
class and try it out.
>>Narrator: This class at Washington
Middle School in Olympia, Washington,
is like hundreds of
others across the country,
where teachers impart vital new
technology skills to their students.
>>Teacher: Creative or...
>>Narrator: But in this
Generation Y class,
the seventh-graders are
doing the teaching...
>>Student: That font is good for
the titles, because it's big.
It's big enough that you
can distinguish the letters,
but when it gets to...
>>Narrator: ...and the
teachers are learning.
>>Teacher: You see
anything you would change?
>>Student: Yeah.
There's no home link here.
I noticed that on your previous
page like you have on here --
and that's really good, but some
browsers don't have Back buttons,
so you have to retype the
URL, which is really annoying.
>>Narrator: Begun in 1996,
the Generation Y program pairs
tech-savvy grade-schoolers
with tech-challenged teachers
to help them integrate new
technology into their lesson plans.
>>Teacher: Right now what we
have is a couple Web sites
for research purposes,
but that's about it,
so what kinds of suggestions do
you think you might have as far
as where to infuse technology?
>>Student: Well, for a
presentation about how we did it
in PowerPoint would be a
good one, because it's...
>>Narrator: Now operating
in over 40 states,
this elegantly simple
concept was the brainchild
of Olympia School District's
technology coordinator,
Dennis Harper.
>>Dennis: I was a former university
college of education trainer
of pre-service teachers,
and typically a lot
of the instruction they get are
from professors who haven't been
in a classroom in 20 years.
There's not a teacher in the
United States that actually went
to K-12 schools when the World
Wide Web was in existence,
so teachers don't realize
the resources.
They don't realize how
sharp these kids are.
They don't realize
that for the first time
in history now we have students
knowing more than their teachers
about something that's really
central and important to society.
>>Student: And Web pages are
just endless possibilities.
>>Teacher: What age do you
recommend that, the Web pages?
>>Student: Web pages?
Well, we got into it a
little bit in fifth grade,
but you basically don't
really do very much with it
until middle school and up.
You can use PowerPoint with younger
age groups and keep it simple,
or you can use it with older age
groups and make it a little fancier.
>>Heather: It's been really helpful
for me to get a student's perspective
on how to infuse technology
in my classroom.
I'm actually learning from
these girls here about where
to put technology, how it's used and
what's in the classrooms right now.
It aligns well with my teaching
philosophy in that I need
to teach what they need to know,
and if they need to learn something,
we need to move in that direction,
and I don't know unless I'm talking
to them and working with them.
>>Teacher: So what we have is Sara
and Hanako are suddenly going to turn
into Ms. Conrad, the partner
teacher, and Sara is meeting
with her for the first time.
Listen carefully for what...
>>Narrator: Gen. Y students also
practice communication skills
and teaching methods so they can
better assist pre-service teachers
with lesson planning.
>>Student: Soundtrack
and transitions.
>>Teacher: What's a transition?
>>Student: Transitions are
you can fade in and fade out
and just like the dials...
>>Narrator: Younger Gen. Y kids
like these fourth-graders help their
classroom teachers learn new skills
like video editing.
>>Teacher: Are there sound
effects that you could use?
>>Student: Yeah.
We have to go into a CD, and
then you export it to iMovie
and you can use it
for the school news.
>>Dennis: The overwhelming majority,
more than 98 percent of the thousands
of teaches that have been involved
with this program have said they
prefer learning from students
than learning from adults.
Teachers go into teaching because
they like to work with kids,
and that's what makes
this model successful.
>>Teacher: I want to
see you guys in it.
Ready?
>>Narrator: Even though
they have to get up early
to attend Gen. Y class before
school each day, these kids return
to the program year after
year, eager to teach and learn.
>>Student: ...or if you
want to cut it smaller,
this will make it smaller.
>>Teacher: Crop it.
>>DeAnne: It's absolutely
joyful to work with these kids.
The more power you give them,
the more empowered they become.
They take responsibility
for their own learning.
They get very excited about having
authentic, purposeful reason to be
at school and authentic ways
of helping their teachers.
They take charge of their
learning and it carries
across into all of the disciplines.
They just really feel that it's
important for them to be here,
that they are the people
who matter in the school.
>>Student: Headings
go with the graphics.
>>Craig: So what I want you to watch
for as James shows his first two
or three slides is: What do
you think are the things...
>>Narrator: Gen. Y instructors
like Craig Costello see more
than a win-win proposition at work.
They see schools being
transformed by the process
of kids training their teachers.
>>Craig: We've got teachers
who are interested in education
because they're about to become
teachers, students who are interested
in the educational process because
they've just had to teach a lesson
for the first time and realized
suddenly how difficult it is,
and experienced teachers who
realize they can't figure
out the technology unless they
get some help from somebody,
so when we meet in that common area,
suddenly we've got something to talk
about together, and the whole culture
of our school has changed
in an easy way.
It hasn't been teachers feeling like,
"I've got to be dragged and pulled
into this technology," kind of thing.
They've got their students working
with them over time on a project,
and then suddenly they have
the skills, and it was kind
of a painless way of
getting the skills.
>>Teacher: Then what happens?
>>Teacher: This looks pretty easy.
Is it ever this easy?
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.